les versaillais peuvent laisser éclater
leur joie l'équipe a encore réalisé une
grosse prestation à domicile ce dimanche
14 octobre contre paris 15 versa il
emporte 26 à 9 avec quatre essais
inscrits y conserve son invincibilité
on a eu un petit passage un petit peu un
temps faible en fin de première période
on a revu les bouchées doubles en début
début de deuxième mi temps et c'est
j'irai pas de sas en force l on affirme
confiance confiance en nos forces on est
au dessus dans le sens où on a confiance
on a confiance en nos forces et quand on
arrive à jouer simplement on peut
arriver à mettre en difficulté n'importe
qui on est très contents très satisfait
l'engagement dégâts et de ce qu'ils
produisent à l'entraînement donc on est
sur la bonne la bonne voie avec cette
victoire les joueurs de la cité royale
s'envole déjà au classement l'équipe
compte quatre points d'avancé sur clichy
après seulement quatre journées dans ce
championnat de division honneur
malgré cette place de leader les versets
qui ne veulent pas s'enflammer
l'excès de confiance avancées
importantes dans la vie c'est comme ça
dès qu'on a un peu trop d'excès je pense
que derrière on peut avoir des
déconvenues donc
voilà il faut rester vigilant travail et
bossez continuer parce que bon il ya la
montée en fédérale 3 mais au prix il yal
aventure aussi humaine avec avec les
garçons et encore plein de matches le
premier le plus important c'est de faire
un premier bloc
le premier blade et 4 mais devait faire
que des victoires on s'attendait pas à
prendre le temps de prendre le bonus
offensif je pense surtout qu'on des
équipes comme rcp 15 étonnant dans ces
tournois c'est tout bon pour continuer à
régner sur la division honneur l'armada
offensive versaillaise ira défier le 11
novembre prochain le clairement club
rugby sur son terrain et pour l'instant
les joueurs peuvent savourer